This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Bellevue Stratford Hotel opened in Philadelphia in 1904 and quickly became one of the most luxurious hotels of its time. It was 19 stories high, had over a thousand guest rooms, and what was said to be the most lavish and magnificent ballroom in the United States. It also featured light fixtures designed by Thomas Edison and a grand marble staircase. The hotel came to be known as the Grand Dom of Broad Street. And for years, the Grand Dom was the center of high society culture in Philadelphia. It hosted presidents and queens and all kinds of other rich and famous guests.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店于1904年在费城开业，很快便成为当时最豪华的酒店之一。它高19层，拥有上千间客房，据称拥有美国最奢华、最宏伟的宴会厅。酒店还配备了托马斯·爱迪生设计的灯具和宏伟的大理石楼梯。这家酒店后来被称为“布罗德街的大圆顶”。多年来，大圆顶一直是费城上流社会文化的中心，接待过总统、女王以及各种各样的富豪名流。
That's producer Alana Gordon from W.H.Y.Y. is the Pulse in Philadelphia. The hotel went through some harder times during the Great Depression and then again in the 50s and 60s. It lost some of the prestige from its early days, but it was always considered one of the nicest places to stay in Philadelphia. in Philadelphia. That is, until the mid-70s, when the Bellevue Shredford Hotel became the epicenter of a series of mysterious deaths that terrified the country. It all started in July of 1976, when more than 2,000 veterans descended on Philadelphia for the Convention of the American Legion, a support organization for wartime vets. The statewide convention happened every year, but in 1976 was a really big deal.
那是来自费城WHYY电台《脉搏》节目的制作人阿拉娜·戈登。在大萧条时期以及50和60年代，这家酒店经历了一些艰难时期。它失去了一些早年的声望，但一直被认为是费城最好的住宿地点之一。直到70年代中期，贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店成为一系列神秘死亡事件的中心，这些事件震惊了全国。这一切始于1976年7月，当时有2000多名退伍军人来到费城参加美国退伍军人协会的年会，这是一个为战时退伍军人提供支持的组织。全州范围的年会每年都会举行，但在1976年，这是一件大事。
The time and place of the convention had been chosen to coincide with the 200th anniversary of the Declaration of Independence signed in Philadelphia in 1776, and the convention would be held in, you guessed it, the Bellevue Stratford Hotel. The gathering was going to be a big party for the members of be held in, you guessed it, the Bellevue Stratford Hotel. The gathering was going to be a big party for the members of the American Legion, a chance for the Legionnaires to celebrate and reminisce. So it's just a big get-together, and then there were a lot of wives and families there at the same time. That's Jasper Stalfur.
年会的时间和地点被选定在费城，以纪念1776年《独立宣言》签署200周年，而年会举办地正如你所猜，就是贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店。这次聚会将是美国退伍军人协会成员的一场盛大派对，是军团成员庆祝和叙旧的机会。所以这只是一次大型聚会，当时还有很多家属和孩子也在场。那是贾斯珀·斯塔尔福。
I am a best department commander of the American Legion. Staufer drove to the convention from South Central Pennsylvania with his wife, and they rode up with another couple, some really close friends of theirs, Charlie Chamberlain and his wife Henrietta. Here's Henrietta, who's now 86, recalling the trip. Well, we were having a good time down there. Everything was going great. The convention ran four days, and the whole thing ended with a big parade of lesionaires through the center of Philadelphia, led by a brass band. On the St. Scow March, you man.
我是美国退伍军人协会的一名分部指挥官。斯塔尔福和妻子从宾夕法尼亚州中南部开车前往年会，他们和另一对非常亲密的朋友——查理·张伯伦和他的妻子亨丽埃塔——同行。现在86岁的亨丽埃塔正在回忆那次旅行。嗯，我们在那里玩得很开心。一切都很顺利。年会持续了四天，整个活动以军团成员在费城市中心的大游行结束，游行由铜管乐队领队。
That was a real pop or song. Henrietta's husband Charlie had just been elected commander of his local legion post, so he was right up front. And they were the one that carried the banner for the parade, and it was wonderful. had just been elected commander of his local legion post. So he was right up front. And they were the one that carried the banner for the parade. And it was wonderful. We had a wonderful time. After the parade, Charlie and Henrietta
那是一首非常流行的歌。亨丽埃塔的丈夫查理刚刚当选为当地军团分部的指挥官，所以他走在最前面。他们是游行中举旗的人，那真是太棒了。我们度过了一段美好的时光。游行结束后，查理和亨丽埃塔
began the drive back home with Jasper and his wife. And Charlie fell asleep, which was strange. He seldom ever slept in the car. But that year, whenever we got on the turnpike of Brandy wine, he went to sleep. He came home and went to bed that night and never got out of bed. I was trying to get him better, but every day he got worse. Charlie's body ached. His temperature kept going up. 104 degrees, 106 degrees.
开始和贾斯珀夫妇开车回家。查理睡着了，这很奇怪。他很少在车里睡觉。但那一年，每当我们开上白兰地酒收费公路时，他就睡着了。他回到家那天晚上就上床睡觉了，从此再也没能下床。我试图让他好起来，但他每天都在恶化。查理全身疼痛，体温不断升高。104华氏度，106华氏度。
Henrietta took him to the hospital. temperature kept going up 104 degrees, 106 degrees. Henrietta took him to the hospital. After taking him in on Wednesday, the nurse, he'd put him under ice, nice blanket, and then Friday he was dead. From a flu of unknown cause, the doctor said, Charlie Chamberlain was dead at the age of 48. I didn't know what to think. Nobody else knew what to think. That was what was strange about it.
亨丽埃塔带他去了医院。体温不断升高，达到104华氏度，106华氏度。亨丽埃塔带他去了医院。周三送他进去后，护士让他躺在冰毯上，到了周五他就去世了。医生说是因为一种不明原因的流感，查理·张伯伦在48岁时去世了。我不知道该想些什么。没人知道该想些什么。这就是最奇怪的地方。
It was a total shock for everybody. Jasper Stalfa remembers that it was during Charlie's funeral, that he realized his friend's death was part of something bigger. I wanted the other members of the headquarters staff was there, and he said that the headquarters were getting all kinds of calls from people that got sick and passed away. Within a week of the convention, weagen headquarters had started getting calls from around the state about members who'd fallen ill.
这对每个人来说都是巨大的打击。贾斯珀·斯塔尔福记得，正是在查理的葬礼上，他意识到朋友的死是更大事件的一部分。总部的工作人员也在场，他说总部接到了各种各样关于人们生病和去世的电话。在年会结束的一周内，军团总部开始接到全州各地关于成员患病的电话。
By that following Monday, nine days after Charlie Chamberlain fell asleep in Stalfurs' car, news of this mysterious respiratory illness had spread across Pennsylvania. No one knew what had caused it, but the Legionnaires who were getting sick had been at the Bellevue Stratford for the convention. Scientists working for the state of Pennsylvania and the federal government are still hard at work this morning trying to determine the cause of the mystery disease that so far. Health leaders back in Philadelphia soon caught wind that something was up. Dr. Robert Charar was director of infectious diseases for the city's health department
到了接下来的周一，也就是查理·张伯伦在斯塔尔福车里睡着后的第九天，这种神秘呼吸道疾病的消息已经传遍了宾夕法尼亚州。没人知道病因，但生病的军团成员都参加了贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店的年会。宾夕法尼亚州和联邦政府的科学家们今天早上仍在努力工作，试图确定这种神秘疾病的病因。费城的卫生领导人很快察觉到出了问题。罗伯特·查拉尔博士是当时该市卫生局的传染病主任。
at the time. All of a sudden I had four lines coming to my office, all four lines were led up at the same time. As someone said there's some sort of an outbreak going on. The death toll logged by the state kept growing. Four deaths, 11 deaths. They called in federal investigators from the Center for Disease Control and Prevention
当时，我办公室里的四条电话线同时响了起来。有人说发生了一种疫情。州政府记录的死亡人数不断增加。4人死亡，11人死亡。他们召集了来自亚特兰大疾病控制与预防中心的联邦调查人员。
in Atlanta. The man charged with overseeing that investigation was David Fraser. He's originally from Philly, and he was 32 at the time. He was the director of the CDC's special pathogens unit. I spent a very intense plane ride trying to figure out how would I systematically begin to approach what looked to be a very complicated problem. Within 48 hours of his arrival, the death toll was nearing 20, with dozens more sick.
负责监督调查的人是戴维·弗雷泽。他来自费城，当时32岁。他是疾控中心特殊病原体部门的主任。我在飞机上度过了一段非常紧张的时光，试图弄清楚如何系统地处理这个看起来非常复杂的问题。在他抵达后的48小时内，死亡人数已接近20人，还有数十人患病。
Some feared this mysterious pneumonia could be the start of a swine flu outbreak, or worse, a flu pandemic like the one that had killed 50 million people in 1918. The authorities readied themselves for the worst, as many as 100 state and federal workers were called in. About 50 police detectives took part. This is the biggest investigation CDC undertook at the time. We needed to define the illness, because this was potentially a new disease. News reporters were already giving it a name,
一些人担心这种神秘的肺炎可能是猪流感爆发的开始，或者更糟，像1918年夺走5000万人生命的流感大流行。当局为最坏的情况做好了准备，多达100名州和联邦工作人员被召集起来。约50名警探参与了调查。这是疾控中心当时承担的最大规模调查。我们需要定义这种疾病，因为它可能是一种新疾病。新闻记者已经给它起了一个名字，
Legionnaires' Disease. State laboratories worked all night. Medical data is being flown in by helicopter as a pressure increases to find the answer. Everybody in the state of Pennsylvania knew about it. We had worldwide recognition. We had phone calls from as far away as Australia asking his questions about it. But scientists still had no idea what was causing the illness. It was a bacteria, a virus, or some sort of toxin. they had to tease out a pattern. Throughout Pennsylvania, health investigators are talking to the more than 100 patients who have the disease but are still alive.
“军团病”。州实验室彻夜工作。医疗数据通过直升机运送，寻找答案的压力越来越大。宾夕法尼亚州的所有人都知道了这件事。我们获得了全球关注。我们接到了远至澳大利亚的电话，询问有关它的问题。但科学家们仍然不知道是什么导致了这种疾病。是细菌、病毒还是某种毒素？他们必须理清规律。在整个宾夕法尼亚州，卫生调查人员正在与100多名患病但仍然活着的患者交谈。
What did they do at the American Legion Convention, where they all together at a single time, or gathered in one location? Question after question. Toine that common link. Defined answers, David Fraser and his investigative squad cast a wide net. Which means we had to send physician epidemiologists out to take histories from and examine a large number of people. They monitored the people who had gotten sick and their families, but they also wanted to talk to people who had been at the convention who hadn't gotten sick. And because there was no central list of who had attended, they distributed questionnaires to hundreds of Legion posts throughout the state.
他们在退伍军人协会年会上做了什么？他们是在同一时间聚在一起，还是聚集在一个地点？问题接踵而至。为了找到共同点，为了找到答案，戴维·弗雷泽和他的调查小组撒下了大网。这意味着我们必须派遣流行病学家去获取大量人员的病史并进行检查。他们监测了生病的人及其家人，但也想与参加了年会但没有生病的人交谈。由于没有一份完整的参会人员名单，他们向全州数百个军团分部发放了调查问卷。
And to have a comparison group, they telephoned random samples of people who weren't even at the convention. And through all this research, it became clear early on that this was not the major flu pandemic that some had feared. The disease seemed confined to the Legionnaires' Convention. But still, Fraser remembers public pressure mounting to figure this out. This was a time when certain infectious diseases were thought to have been largely worked out and controlled.
为了有一个对照组，他们随机电话采访了甚至没有参加年会的样本人群。通过所有这些研究，早期就很清楚，这并不是一些人所担心的那种重大流感大流行。这种疾病似乎仅限于军团年会。但弗雷泽记得，查明真相的公众压力越来越大。那是一个人们认为某些传染病已基本被解决和控制的时代。
It challenged assumptions. And it increased the fear. Maybe it was something people ate or drank. Some people even thought it could have been an act of bioterrorism by a disgruntled veteran. Investigators were stumped, but Robert Charar with Philadelphia's health department says they did have one general suspect in mind. It's called the Grand Old Lady of Broad Street. I mean, that's what I've always heard referred to, and she was the Grand Old Lady of Broad Street.
它挑战了假设，也增加了恐惧。也许是人们吃或喝了什么东西。有些人甚至认为这可能是一个心怀不满的退伍军人进行的生物恐怖主义行为。调查人员被难住了，但费城卫生局的罗伯特·查拉尔说，他们确实有一个主要的怀疑对象。它被称为“布罗德街的老贵妇”。我的意思是，我一直听到人们这样称呼它，它就是布罗德街的老贵妇。
Charar says the Grand Old Lady, some say the Grand Dom. But yes, he's referring to the Bellevue Stratford Hotel. Perhaps this iconic landmark of the city was the killer. Investigators flagged it in their reports, and it didn't take long for this to become a media frenzy. The Bellevue Stratford may still hold a key to solving the mystery of Legionnaire's disease. Somewhere in this hotel, there may be an environment.
查拉尔说“老贵妇”，也有人说“大圆顶”。但没错，他指的是贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店。也许这个城市的地标性建筑就是杀手。调查人员在报告中标记了它，没过多久，这便演变成了一场媒体狂热。“贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店可能仍掌握着解开军团病之谜的钥匙。在这家酒店的某个地方，可能存在某种环境。”
And it was like hysteria. That's Steve Hornstein. He was a dormant at the Bellevue at the time of the outbreak. Bright eyed, 21-year-old, looking to break into the hotel business. He remembers people started calling into cancel reservations. They feared the place, and anything or anyone associated with it. I was dating a young lady, and I remember she told me her mom didn't want me to come to the house anymore because I worked at the Bellevue.
那简直是歇斯底里。那是史蒂夫·霍恩斯坦。疫情爆发时，他是贝尔维尤酒店的门童。21岁，目光炯炯，想进入酒店业。他记得人们开始打电话取消预订。他们害怕这个地方，以及与它有关的任何人和事。我当时正在和一个年轻女士约会，我记得她告诉我，她妈妈不想让我再去她家了，因为我在贝尔维尤工作。
And the hotel was losing guests. We were going down for the count and each day would get a little worse. They would have the engineer turn on lamps in the Broad Street rooms so that the lights were on in the evening and it wasn't all dark. That's how bad it got. in the evening and it wasn't old dark. That's how bad it got. But for David Fraser, the director of the CDC's Special Pathogens Unit, there was only one way to get to the bottom of this.
酒店正在失去客源。我们正处于崩溃边缘，每一天情况都会变得更糟。他们会让工程师打开布罗德街客房的灯，这样晚上灯亮着，就不会一片漆黑。情况就是这么糟糕。但对于疾控中心特殊病原体部门主任戴维·弗雷泽来说，只有一种方法能查明真相。
After spending the first week of the investigation in the state capital of Harrisburg, he and several others joined the Philadelphia crew on the ground. And guess where they stayed? Because there were rooms available, and we got a good price. Fraser brought his team to the Bellevue. He really wanted to solve this mystery.
在州首府哈里斯堡度过调查的第一周后，他和另外几个人加入了费城的现场团队。猜猜他们住在哪里？因为那里有空房，而且价格优惠。弗雷泽把他的团队带到了贝尔维尤。他真的想解开这个谜团。
There was part of me that was hoping that somebody got sick. He's only half joking. This might give an important clue. They got to work trying to figure out the source of the disease. Maybe it was somehow traveling through the elevator shafts. And I thought perhaps the elevator would permit an agent to waft into the air as the elevator went up and down, but we found no evidence. Other theories blame the pigeons perched on the window ledges.
我内心深处有一部分希望有人生病。他只是半开玩笑。这可能会提供重要的线索。他们开始努力寻找疾病的来源。也许它是通过电梯井传播的。我曾想，也许电梯在上下运行时，会让某种病原体飘进空气中，但我们没有发现证据。其他理论则归咎于栖息在窗台上的鸽子。
Maybe the pigeons were the source. Maybe the lady who feeds the pigeons out on the sidewalk was the source. In the end, they came up with two leads. First, the more time people spent in a lobby of the hotel, the more at risk they were for contracting the disease. And second, the more time people spent just outside the hotel on the sidewalk, the greater the risk. Even some people who had nothing to do with a hotel
也许鸽子是来源。也许在人行道上喂鸽子的女士是来源。最终，他们得出了两条线索。第一，人们在酒店大堂待的时间越长，感染疾病的风险就越大。第二，人们在酒店外的人行道上待的时间越长，风险就越大。甚至一些与酒店或年会无关的人，如果他们在人行道上待过，也生病了。
or the convention had gotten sick, if they'd spent time on the sidewalk. None of David Fraser's staff became ill while staying in the hotel, but they also couldn't figure out what it was about the place that I got in everyone else's sick. And so people's fear of the building persisted.
戴维·弗雷泽的员工在酒店住宿期间没有人患病，但他们也无法弄清楚这个地方到底有什么导致了其他所有人的生病。因此，人们对这座建筑的恐惧持续存在。
And in November of 1976, the Grand Dom of Broad Street was forced to close. It had already been in financial trouble, but the outbreak was the final fatal blow. It was the end of an era for a very elegant hotel with all kinds of memories in Philadelphia history. It was the final day today for the Grand Old Bellevue Stratford Hotel in Philadelphia, battered and finally done in by the fact that people died after attending the American Legion Convention there. Occupancy used to be a- After one final party, Hornstein helped lock the place up. We had put the chains on the door at the front door and we put it around the grab handles.
1976年11月，布罗德街的大圆顶被迫关闭。它本已陷入财务困境，但疫情是最后一击。对于一家在费城历史上承载了各种记忆的优雅酒店来说，这是一个时代的终结。今天是费城贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店的最后一天，它因人们在参加美国退伍军人协会年会后死亡的事实而受挫并最终倒闭。在最后一场派对后，霍恩斯坦帮忙锁上了大门。我们把链条锁在正门上，绕在把手上。
So the doors couldn't open with a padlock. It was like a death sentence. I don't think there'll ever be another hotel that big and bustling like that one was on Broad Street. Back in the CDC labs, scientists continued reviewing samples and running more tests. Weeks went by.
所以门无法用挂锁打开。这就像死刑判决。我不认为布罗德街上还会再有像那家酒店那样规模宏大、熙熙攘攘的酒店了。回到疾控中心的实验室，科学家们继续审查样本并进行更多测试。几周过去了。
It was a very high pressure, very frustrating. David Fraser and his colleagues were eventually called into Congress to account for why they still hadn't solved the mystery. We expected to be raked over the coals for failing to solve an outbreak and we were raked over the coals. It was a very unpleasant couple of hours. Fraser worried about morale. Some of the CDC scientists had spent years trying to solve other outbreaks with no success. Which I was afraid was going to set in with lead
压力非常大，非常令人沮丧。戴维·弗雷泽和他的同事最终被传唤到国会，解释为什么他们还没能解开这个谜团。我们预料到会因为未能解决疫情而受到严厉批评，我们也确实受到了严厉批评。那是令人非常不快的几个小时。弗雷泽担心士气。一些疾控中心的科学家花了几年时间试图解决其他疫情却毫无进展。我担心这种情绪会蔓延。
generes to these two. Did you think maybe it would take years? Yes, I hope it would only take years. Five and a half months had passed since the first death. Around 30 people had died. The grown-up dome had closed. Things were not looking good. And then finally, the CDC caught a break. A scientist named Joseph McDade was combing through all the biological specimens they collected from victims' lungs and re-examining them, looking for something he might have missed.
你认为这可能需要几年时间吗？是的，我希望只需要几年。距离第一次死亡已经过去了五个半月。大约30人死亡。大圆顶已经关闭。情况看起来很不妙。然后，疾控中心终于有了突破。一位名叫约瑟夫·麦克戴德的科学家正在梳理他们从受害者肺部收集的所有生物标本，并重新检查它们，寻找他可能遗漏的东西。
McDade said this process was like looking for a contact lens on the floor of a basketball court, but then finally, on December 27th, he found that contact lens. In his microscope, it looked like a red cluster of tiny rods. McDade ran tests and found these tiny rods were part of a bacteria, one they hadn't seen before. Within a few weeks, they confirmed that this was indeed the bacteria that had caused the disease. On January 17th, 1977, CDC scientists announced their findings with great fanfare. I was so excited. This was such a spectators of great weight off my shoulders and a great discovery of
麦克戴德说，这个过程就像在篮球场地板上寻找隐形眼镜，但最终，在12月27日，他找到了那枚“隐形眼镜”。在他的显微镜下，它看起来像一簇红色的微小杆状物。麦克戴德进行了测试，发现这些微小的杆状物是一种细菌，一种他们以前从未见过的细菌。几周内，他们证实这确实是导致疾病的细菌。1977年1月17日，疾控中心的科学家们大张旗鼓地宣布了他们的发现。我太兴奋了。这让我如释重负，这是一个伟大的发现。
a very, very special discovery. They called the new bacteria, Lysianella Numafala. They had found the fatal bacteria. David Fraser and his colleagues went from being humiliated to congratulated. But wait a minute. Where have the bacteria come from? This question wouldn't be answered until a couple years after the bacteria was discovered. David Fraser retraces his steps around the outside of the Bellevue nearly 40 years after the outbreak. The Grand Hotel was restored and
一个非常、非常特别的发现。他们将这种新细菌命名为“嗜肺军团菌”。他们找到了致命的细菌。戴维·弗雷泽和他的同事们从受辱变成了受到祝贺。但等一下，细菌是从哪里来的？这个问题直到细菌被发现几年后才得到解答。在疫情爆发近40年后，戴维·弗雷泽重走了贝尔维尤酒店外围的路线。这家大酒店在1979年修复并重新开放。
reopened in 1979. He points up to the very top of the building's roof. There are cooling towers, which would operate to eject heat from from the hotel. Fraser explains that Legionella bacteria occurs naturally in the environment, which can make it hard to pin down a specific source. But it really likes to grow in warm water, and one ideal environment is the warm water basins in air conditioning systems. When those systems convert warm water into cold air, they produce a mist as a by-product. And that mist can come across the edge of the roof and layer down the side of a building.
他指着大楼屋顶的最顶端。那里有冷却塔，用于排出酒店的热量。弗雷泽解释说，军团菌在环境中自然存在，这使得很难确定具体的来源。但它确实喜欢在温水中生长，一个理想的环境是空调系统中的温水盆。当这些系统将温水转化为冷空气时，它们会产生一种副产品——水雾。而这种水雾可以飘过屋顶边缘，沿着建筑物侧面飘落。
It's one of the curious things about airflow in cities. If that mist carries lesionella bacteria and is inhaled, it can make you sick. That's why people who are right outside the hotel and inside the front lobby were most likely to get infected. Fraser says contaminated mist from the Belvies cooling tower would have likely dropped down the side of the hotel exposing people on the sidewalk. And then? So here's some of these utility events here.
这是城市气流中奇特的事情之一。如果这种水雾携带军团菌并被吸入，就会让人患病。这就是为什么在酒店外面和前厅里面的人最容易被感染。弗雷泽说，来自贝尔维尤冷却塔的受污染水雾很可能沿着酒店侧面落下，接触到人行道上的人。然后呢？这里有一些公用设施管道。
It also would have been sucked into a vent near the ground that leads right into the front lobby, exposing people there. The air conditioning system had always been a possible culprit as a breeding ground for the Legionella bacteria. But the CDC couldn't say for sure right away because the Belfew Stratford's cooling system had been thoroughly cleaned following the outbreak. By the time the CDC got there to get samples, there was no Legionella bacteria present. But as the years passed, there were more outbreaks of Legionnaires in other places.
它也可能被吸入靠近地面、通向前厅的通风口，从而接触到那里的人。空调系统一直被认为是军团菌滋生的潜在罪魁祸首。但疾控中心无法立即确定，因为贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店的冷却系统在疫情爆发后已经彻底清洗过了。当疾控中心去取样时，已经没有军团菌了。但随着时间的推移，其他地方也出现了更多的军团病疫情。
And in those instances, they were able to confirm that the bacteria had come from the cooling systems. Researchers retroactively linked the bacteria to previously unsolved outbreaks, including a smaller one at the Bellevue a couple years before the 76 Legionnaires Convention. In the public health community, the story of Legionnaires' disease has turned into a sort of poster trial for the power of epidemiology. That shoe leather detective work that's used to map out
在这些案例中，他们能够证实细菌确实来自冷却系统。研究人员追溯性地将这种细菌与之前未解决的疫情联系起来，包括76年军团年会前几年在贝尔维尤发生的一起较小的疫情。在公共卫生界，军团病的故事已成为流行病学力量的某种典范。那种用于绘制模式、理解疾病如何移动和袭击的“鞋底侦探工作”。但不幸的是，这种疾病的发现并没有导致它的消亡。
patterns and understand how diseases move and strike. But unfortunately, the discovery of the disease didn't lead to its demise. The government now has recommendations for how to design and maintain cooling systems, so they're not breeding grounds for Legionella. But even though the disease is treatable, there are still a lot of cases. In 2015, New York had an outbreak that was traced to an old opera house in the Bronx. Twelve people died and more than 120 became sick. As for the Bellevue Stratford, cleaning the cooling tower is now a routine part of the building's maintenance. They also analyze water samples.
政府现在有关于如何设计和维护冷却系统的建议，这样它们就不会成为军团菌的滋生地。但尽管这种疾病是可以治疗的，病例仍然很多。2015年，纽约爆发了一场疫情，追溯到布朗克斯区的一家老歌剧院。12人死亡，120多人患病。至于贝尔维尤斯特拉特福酒店，清洗冷却塔现在是建筑维护的常规部分。他们还会分析水样。
And during a major restoration in the 80s, the hotel got a completely new heating and cooling system. These days business is good for the Grand Dom of Broadstream. The hotel, now owned by Hyatt, has been modernized, but it still has that classic feel. Rooms run upwards of $500 a night and feature king size beds, views of downtown Philly, 42-inch flat screen TVs, and of course, in the summertime. Ice-cold air conditioning. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Alana Gordon, Delaney Hall, and Katie Mingle. With Sam Greenspan, Avery Troubleman, Kirk Cole Stead, Sharif Usef, and me Roman Mars.
在80年代的一次重大修复中，酒店更换了全新的供暖和制冷系统。如今，布罗德街的大圆顶生意兴隆。这家酒店现在由凯悦酒店集团拥有，已经实现了现代化，但仍然保留着那种经典的感觉。客房每晚价格在500美元以上，配有特大号床、费城市中心景观、42英寸平板电视，当然，在夏天还有冰凉的空调。《99%隐形》本周由阿拉娜·戈登、德莱尼·霍尔和凯蒂·明格尔制作。参与制作的还有萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁布尔曼、柯克·科尔斯特德、谢里夫·尤塞夫和我，罗曼·马尔斯。
A version of this story originally aired on The Pulse from WHY in Philadelphia, The Pulse Covered Stories at the heart of health, science, and innovation. We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced at the offices of ArcSide, the grandest architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebooking, follow us all on Twitter and Instagram, but the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to click around the hundreds of stories that comprise 99pi.org.
这个故事的一个版本最初在费城WHYY电台的《脉搏》节目中播出，《脉搏》涵盖了健康、科学和创新核心的故事。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的ArcSide建筑与室内设计公司办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目，在Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，但探索塑造我们世界设计的《99%隐形》活动的最好方式，是点击浏览99pi.org上数百个故事。
Radio toio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX的RadioToio。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。